[Music]
this is a show where we talk about what
the internet is talking about and today
the internet is talking about a fellow
named shridhar chillal he's been growing
his fingernails for six decades he had
the Guinness Book of World Records and
he just decided to cut them guys what do
you think's the first thing he's gonna
do now that he's cut his freakishly long
fingernails he's gonna open all the jars
of Mayo in assume he has many unopened
jars of mail yeah well I think he had
the he only on one hand with long
fingernails right no he was probably
using his strong hand to do that yeah I
guess you could did you watch the video
I couldn't sit through it it was like I
wanted to like see his face cuz it's
like 66 years that's longer than most
marriages and he's like losing his nails
and I was just like the thing I was
focused on most was that he had a watch
on it was like a nice watch on his like
club fingernail hand no that's smart cuz
no one's gonna want to get near it to
try to steal it that's like if you had a
briefcase full of diamonds handcuffed it
to that hand didn't weren't the
fingernails like one of them was like as
long as a bus its Lunden specified a
London 30 feet long finger now you look
grossed out yeah
are you grossed out yeah I'm just keep
thinking he might just use the the new
for the free hand to like just
masturbate cuz it's like in a cool fun
shape now and I bet he's just excited
about that do you think he wasn't
already using fingernail hand to
masturbate oh I don't know yeah maybe he
gets all on it he's like oh this is the
crazy hand it's like his version of this
stranger that
now that it's explained your hand falls
asleep you sit on your hand so falls
asleep and then you masturbate it with
it so it feels like someone else is
doing it okay literally raise your hand
if you have not done that they know what
it is but I haven't done it yeah I've
heard I mean it's like a thing in movies
but you never like as the one I don't
want like a stranger a matter of
stranger putting a finger on you a
stranger
we wouldn't trust you of us trade this
is some sort of like Locks of Love yeah
totally back scratchers fortunate just
creepy maybe a wind chime that this guy
like got the world record like decades
ago and just was like I guess I'll just
keep it well you know what's the reason
supposedly the article said is a teacher
when he was 14 said like don't cut your
fingernails or something or like berated
him for having a long finger now so then
up until that point he's just like
followed his like teachers guys he's
just rebelling against the man no no the
teacher scolded him for cutting his
finger
and so he was like okay I'll be a good
student and has continued well it's the
biggest load of like my teachers I got
to cover and they're like growing like
it's like heavy on his hand he's like
this she said not to but as a lot the
guy is married your teacher I always
like that's inspirational listen I don't
know I feel like it he did say enough
like a really strong like pointer finger
like you got a restaurant he's like that
one hey I think it's time to do some
shoutouts how do you guys hate Chris
what's the what's today's YouTube
shoutouts okay shout out to Savi Baker
you put a comment up on the polls in the
community for what I should do next and
you said call to see what time it is and
movie times the day of pay fold and
cause on landlines are dead I don't know
what he said but either way like Timmy
Baker thank you it just doesn't take me
a movie phone shout out but he said it
very unclear Lee I like movie phone
that's when you call it a day hey what
time is Nick moving hello welcome to
Moviefone
[Laughter]
watch the next back in my name please
what that poll is about on the YouTube
community and we might put her in some
fashion on the show hi I'm Hannah
Dickinson and this is cheer see you
where I'm kicking off my first round of
the weekend by cheering to all the
people and stories that encouraged me to
drink cheers to you woman who stuck a
kinder egg up her hoo-ha I don't know
how you did that all of my chocolate
pulls out and then deletes me from their
contacts cheers to you Kylie Jenner for
deflating your lips it's so brave you
decide to stick to very heavy makeup and
also cheers to you for making the cover
of Forbes self-made billionaire woman
it's good to know men date you for more
than just your looks
cheers to Elon Musk for your child size
submarine that was rejected by the Thai
government they said it was not
practical for this mission which is
exactly what women say about your penis
[Music]
all right cheers to you cardi B for
naming your baby girl culture I'm so
excited to watch her grow up into a big
bowl of yogurt Cheers new Justin Bieber
and Haley Baldwin on your engagement I'm
so happy you guys got back together I
really missed you too as the Coors Light
twins cheers to you Amazon Prime day for
selling cheap condoms making safe sex
easy and fun it's a lot like Disney
World
not for me you know cheers me for making
three out of the seven joke stick jokes
Cheers
[Music]
in this segment I eat something really
hot and learn something new with me as
always is my professor actual doctor of
sociology Nate Dern he's gonna be
teaching me something so let's find out
what I'm gonna eat today's burn is
habanero pepper that was last time these
look mean it's the same burn
today's learn you want to eat the bigger
one of the smaller one bigger one this
is the big okay
today's learn is confirmation bias Oh
[Music]
begin eating the pepper Ryan
yeah Ryan as you eat the pepper and you
must eat all of it please read this card
this will teach you about confirmation
it's a pretty long Oh begin reading
confirmation bias is a tendency to favor
information that confirms one's
pre-existing beliefs and to dismiss
information contrary to those beliefs
the effect is stronger for emotionally
charged beliefs
confirmation bias can explain the
phenomenon in attitude polarization when
a disagreement becomes foamy more
extreme even though the different
parties are exposed to the same evidence
their belief person
and swin believes mm-hmm just after the
evidences for them to show to be false
the irrational prime primacy of it back
bucket reliance on information
encountered in early in this series no
lose correlation when people fastly
perceive an association between two
events or situations you a series of
questions only when you have correctly
answered all the questions well Hannah
number one initial thoughts your eyes
are watering
I need any word it's really long it's
really long great I'll accept question
two in a way that a grandpa would
understand what is confirmation bias
leading the car back you think one thing
and then and then you you just confirm
it do you think one thing and then you
confirm it I'll accept it in 1968
psychologist Klaus Conrad coined the
term a profane iya to refer to the
related universal human tendency to seek
patterns and random information what is
the name of the psychologist that I said
three seconds ago where do you exhibit
confirmation bias in your last question
for the betterment of society please
outline a three-step plan so that we can
combat confirmation bias in the
reception of all talking to strangers
why I said okay take your bubble
traveling traveling to a place that's
good that's great trying new foods
[Music]
hair was there in hair the final prank
was a Dirty Harry glad we've got to go
[Applause]
it's not my saliva saliva
[Laughter]
[Music]
you